I want us to come back our minds to what
we're looking at these and you can we
didn't work out the pants up what I was
just interested in was the process now
if I'm trying to choose a new unit right
that makes this nita and avoids this
conversion business okay then a sensible
idea a sensible proposal is why not
choose a unit that involves high now
that seems a bit counterintuitive at
first because likewise a gross number pi
is irrational but it's not even
imaginable
it's transcendental sort of the most
complicated number you could possibly
choose but the reason I'm choosing is
because it has to be there anyway do you
notice that right if you're measuring
circles you cannot avoid pi it's there
whether you like it or not so being that
it's there why not incorporate it into
our calculations okay for instance see
this for America we're looking at video
mister come to play the for
circumference is 2 pi times whatever the
radius is 2 pi takes you all the way
around if I have some proportion of that
like for example if I just apply that
would not be about all the way around it
must be halfway so I'm gonna introduce
is a new way of vision and that's what
this Sun is pair of diagrams as well ok
so if you are just mimic that diagram if
you never don't put the base on it
so what I've got here is a second
generic circle right and I want you to
find so this is by definition
here comes right for what is the size of
this angle AOB right hey today this is
my definition so maybe I want to take it
as the ratio between this radius which
is kind of locked in and then however
much of these circumference you've got
the up okay so being that it's the ratio
it's going to be in this diagram I'll be
probably I'm going to call that a B for
that a that up and I'm gonna divide by
the radius now I have two ways to
collaborate just because I so this is
what I'm defining is the size of that
angle right I'm comparing an arc length
to the radius of the circle now the
genius of this the beauty of it is that
as this circle grows or shrinks because
this is a ratio this angle will always
stay the same okay so for instance if I
went like I said and did the entire
thing when I don't release because of a
markup language but if I went all the
way around okay
what would the arc length be for that
word is subtended by this angle it's
going to be 2 PI R isn't it because
that's what the circumference is so be
to apply but then I'm dividing by I'm
comparing that to the radius right so
our claim our radius so that would tell
me the whole angle is too high that's
where this comes from going all the way
around if I say only wanted to go half
way so if we would call that normally
halfway we would call that a hundred and
80 degrees instead of doing that well
what I clicked will you trace if you go
halfway around the circle Marcus but it
will only be PI R right but then you
compare it to the radius so pi is the
angle that takes you halfway around the
circle
okay one more try one more common angle
that we deal with right what's a right
angle in atoms it's 90 degrees right how
far around the circle doesn't write
anything take you and the entries are
caught up right so therefore instead of
PI R or R right I'm going to have on -
that's how far I've gone around the
circle and I'm going to compare that to
that make sense like this he is a
quartile of the full circumference
that's why it's not pirate for that's
priority another question play on two so
PI on two is what I'm used to thinking
of as a writing it takes me a quarter of
the way around assessment so this is all
really nice but let's generalize this
even further - of A or B or a Rebecca we
redraw the diagram of this labeler a
little bit differently
because what we're dealing with is an
arc length right that's the that's the
key thing but Ron we call that a V it's
a length so I'm just gonna use the
letter L before okay and I stylize the L
so I don't confuse it with the rid of
one okay so if I call this the other
claim this of course is just the radius
we wait used to coin that are from like
to my own PI R squared and so on
and if I just generically call this
angle clean up that means that by
definition again theta is equal to the
ratio between the arc length which is
just terrible and the radius so a couple
of things leap out of you right this is
all about my boxes around us now
this is all about trying to work out
okay what's the size of the same okay
but if I come back to the questions we
saw before usually I cut a note at the
end an angle is easy to measure out and
what I what is the arc length so I need
to do to get an expression for R going
down this is just rearranged just change
the subject
right if I'm a arc length which is hell
if I've made that the subject how would
I write this thing I would say L and I
multiply both sides by ah and this is
the first inverted commas formula for
what we encounter in Oracle Radian
measure and measuring stones certain
integer
okay this is the formula for arc length
which jumps out on how we've defined
what a Radian what an angle is now on
the second thing is what would it mean
if I said like we're trying to deal with
we said the whole thing is the whole
thing is 2 pi right so that's like what
is 2 pi it's a number it's about six
point two eight right you agree with
that so six point two men takes me all
the way around now we have a pretty
intuitive sense of what like one degree
is or what 90 degrees is in 118 reasons
what would one Radian look like now
these are good thing about right I don't
have to guess I can just say well what
if that thing is equal one it would
equal L Oh what does that tell me this
means that in this case in this case if
I were to imagine an angle that was
exactly one developers radio that angle
will trace out an arc length that is
exactly the same as the radius okay
I like Vidura third circuit between if I
were to have a circle and I know it's
radius is that long then if you can
estimate for yourself how far would you
have to go around the circumference in
order to get on a plane it's exactly the
same way by the same centers and it is
not all that far about I think I wanted
to buy
if you check right how am I going to
work out what is the true size of that
angle in all the terms of the degrees
tips and I'm already familiar with right
we have all the tools you need in these
kinds of combinations here let's put
some names on it so 2 pi we call this
this is a revolution right all right
that was halfway around the circle what
do we normally call that start awareness
my 38 degrees is a it's a straight line
nice and Colitis training right and of
course PI on to that represents a
quarter of the way around the circle and
we call that away right now the thing is
we know the reason why I'm calling your
attention to these these names is
because you know exactly what each of
these is in degrees right so this part
is equivalent to 360 degrees and this is
equivalent to 180 degrees and this is
equivalent to 90 degrees now you can
take any of these they'll give you the
same conversion but it looks to me like
this is the easiest one this one has no
other numbers involved so if pi radians
represents a straight angle how many
degrees is that that's 180 degrees right
so I'm going to write it like this and
this is me trying to wrap my head around
like what is one radiant like would I
have a feature in my head okay one
rating this human butt
the abbreviation rat I'm going to get
rid of it in a second or two late
library two pi radians is the same as
one hundred and eighty degrees so how do
I get one rating of this divide both
sides by PI 1 Radian is a hundred and
eighty degrees divided by a PI which
from my memory is about fifty seven
point three degrees you can pump it in
your calculator and confirm that fifty
seven point three units can you picture
fifty seven point three degrees I guess
you got a right angle your Harbert that
gives you forty five you've got a little
bit further right you got a little bit
further which is how are you happy go I
know I'm in the right ballpark okay you
can estimate your arc length and your
radius that you should see they're about
the same so you might like to write me
up it's approximately it's all want to
check I'm not just making that up about
fifty seven point three yeah yeah